alors l'information c'est effectivement
l'augmentation tout à fait significative
de la capacité de réaction du système de
santé français
si l'épidémie devait revenir le
gouvernement assure que c'est le cas
mais je vous rappelle qu'il avait assuré
en janvier que la france était le pays
le mieux préparé du monde à une épidémie
donc de ce point de vue sa capacité à
convaincre est encore un petit peu en
deçà de ce qui serait nécessaire
on peut penser que ce que dit le
ministre est vrai on peut penser aussi
que ce que dit le ministre et proche de
ce que disait madame busin qui l'a
précédée il y a quelques mois encore
c'est à dire quelque chose qui indique
une volonté un espoir un souhait mais
pas forcément une réalité est là les
français n'ont pas d'autres moyens de
juger
ils peuvent faire confiance de manière
absolue au gouvernement ou pas